โอเคสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะ
ครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนอืมาเจอกันวันอะไรคะครูฟ้าาวันนี้
วันพุธค่ะครูเรียมวันพุธวันนี้วันพุธวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
อืเดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุลาค
โคปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีพเอ้ยอันนี้พ.ศต่อไปค.ศค.ศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะโอเคตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้
เวลา
น
14:47 นค่ะโอเค
14:47 นาทีอืโหครูฟ้าก็ไอ
อ่ะนิดหน่อยนะคะนิดหน่อยเออเรียมก็รู้สึก
แบบอ๋อเหมือนจะแบบมีไข้โอ้ครูเรียมเป็น
อะไรคะเราไม่สบายหรอเหมือนจะไม่
สบายคือตอนนี้อากาศหนาวมากใช่ในประเทศไทย
นะคะนักเรียนอากาศหนาวอืหนาวมากแต่ว่าถ้า
เกิดออกไปออกไปนอกบ้านอก็จะแบบร้อนมาก
ร้อนมาก
โออยู่ในบ้านหนาวอืออกไปข้างนอกบ้านร้อน
ใช่เพราะนอกบ้านมีมีพระอาทิตย์อืมใช่
แต่อยู่ในบ้านอยู่ในบ้านมันจะหนาวนะมันจะ
หนาวๆเอ้าครูเรียมร้อนหนาวร้อนหนาวร้อน
หนาวร้อนหนาวก็ไม่สบายสิคะแบบนี้ใช่ค่ะ
อโอก็เลยคิดว่าไม่
สบายตอนนี้ตัวร้อน
อืทำยังไงล่ะครูริมเดี๋ยวิมจะกิน
ยา
กินยาครูียมยังไม่ได้กินยาใช่ไหมยคะยัง
ค่ะครูฟ้าอืมียานะยาพาราเซตามอลยาไทลินอล
ใช่่มยเออต้องกินนะคะครูเรียมเพราะว่า
เดี๋ยวครูเรียมเนี่ยถ้าเกิดครูเรียมไม่
กินยาครูเรียมก็จะไม่สบายมากๆใช่มอือืไม่
สบายมากๆหรือว่าพูดได้ว่าป่วยหนักอืป่วย
ป่วยไม่สบายเหมือนกันนะคะนักเรียนนัก
เรียนพูดป่วยก็ได้ไม่สบายก็ได้อือืถ้า
เกิดแบบป่วยมากๆก็ใช้พูดว่าแบบป่วยหนักก็
ได้นะใช่ค่ะป่วยหนักบางคนป่วยหนักต้องไป
แอดมิโรงพยาบาลใช่มยไปนอนพี่ปอพี่ปอพี่ปอ
ไปโรงพยาบาลเลยนะคะอืป่วยหนักใช่โคเรียม
เคยป่วยหนัก
มยเตรียมเคยค่ะเคยป่วยหนักอืเราต้องไปที่
โรงพยาบาลไป
นอนครูเรียมเคยป่วยหนักตอนอายุเท่าไหร่คะ
โหเรียมจำไม่ได้แบบลืมลืมเพราะว่าเป็น
เด็กมากๆประมาณได้มยประมาณ 10 ประมาณ
20 ไม่อ่ะไม่ถึง 10 ประมาณ 8  8  9 ขวบ 8
ขวบอืมครูเรียมประมาณ 8 ขวบ 9 ขวบนะคะอื
ใช่ค่ะป่วยหนักเลยหรอใช่ตอนนั้นก็คือแบบ
มีไข้ตัว
ร้อนครูเรียมทำอะไรมาครูเรียมเดินฝนตกหรอ
หรือ
ว่ามันจะเป็นแบบฤดูหนาวอ่ะอที่อากาศหนาว
มากๆอใช่มยคนไทยส่วนใหญ่จะป่วยหรือว่าไม่
สบายในฤดูหนาวนะคะถ้าเกิดหนาวเนี่ยก็จะ
ป่วยหรือว่าไม่สบายได้อืมใช่เรียมก็ไม่
สบายตอนฤดูหนาวใช่มั้ยใช่แล้วเรียมก็เป็น
เด็กเรียมก็แบบแม่ให้เสื่อใส่เสื้อกัน
หนาวที่แบบหนาๆเสื้อหนาๆก็แบบไม่ไม่ใส่อื
เยิ่งเล่นอือๆเห็นมยแล้วอากาศก็หนาวครู
เรียมก็ไม่ใส่เสื้อสเวตเตอร์ไม่ใส่ฮูดดี้
ไม่ใส่เสื้อกันหนาวอ่ะมันก็หนาวไม่ค่ะไม่
อืแล้วก็เลยแบบอมีไข้ตัวร้อน
นอนนอนแล้วก็แบบไม่กินข้าว
อืใช่ไม่กินข้าวด้วยอืว่าครูเรียมเนี่ย
เอ่อบอกว่าครูเรียมเนี่ยพอหนักครูเรียมก็
ป่วยใช่มั้ยคะไม่สบาย
ใช่เป็นยังไงบ้างคะครูเรียมตอนที่ไม่สบาย
มีอะไรบ้างตัวร้อนไอด้วยนะมี
ไอไอใช่ตัวร้อนมยคะตัวร้อนค่ะตัวร้อน 40
องศเซซใช่โอโหแล้วก็นอนอืห่มผ้าอืหนาวมย
หนวหนาวอืหนาวมากนอนนอนอยู่ที่บ้านอ
ประมาณ 2
วัน 2 วันก็คือไม่ไปโรงเรียนอืมใช่ค่ะไม่
ไปโรงเรียนอ่าแล้วก็กินยา
อืกินยาแต่ว่าก็ไม่ไม่ดีขึ้นอืนอนเยอะๆ
นอน 2 วันแล้วกินยาแล้วก็ยังไม่ดีขึ้นทำ
ยังไงครูเรียมทำยังไงต่อแม่ก็เลยพาเรียม
ไปโรงพยาบาลต้องไปโรงพยาบาลเลยเหรอคะพี่
โปพี่โปไปโรงพยาบาลใช่มยอืใช่ค่ะแล้วคุณ
หมอคุณหมอก็เลยมาตรวจอืคุณหมอบอกให้เรียม
หายใจ
เข้าหายใจออกช้า
ๆอืมหายใจหายใจเข้าหายใจออกอืแล้วคุณหมอ
ก็เช็คดูว่าครูเรียมป่วยอะไรอืใช่ใช่อ่า
เป็นังไงบ้างหมอก็เลยบอกว่าเรียมเป็นปอด
บวมปอดปวมครูเรียมว่าดปอดปอบปอปอดนะคะนัก
เรียนปอดอปอดใช่มั้
อืเหมือนมั้ยเนี่ยเวลาเราหายใจเข้า
ไป
ปอดเดี๋ยวนักเรียนทุกคนนมีปอดนะคะเรามี
ปอด 2 ใช่มั้ยคะ 2  1  2
ปอดใช่ปอดบวมนี่คือปอดมันใหญ่ขึ้นหรอคะ
ครูเรียมใช่ปอดใหญ่มากขึ้นออโหปอด
ป่วมใช่แล้วทำยังไงูเรียมมันูเรียมต้องทำ
ยังไงต่อหมอก็ฉีดยาอืฉีดยานะคะใช่ฉีดยา
ที่ก้นน่ะอันนี้ปากกาแต่ว่าสมมุติเนาะ
เข็มแล้วก็ฉีดยาอืมใช่มต้องฉีดยานะคะฉีด
ยาใช่คุณหอกก็ต้องฉีดยาใช่ไมยใช่ค่ะฉีดยา
เรียมจำได้ว่าฉีดยาฉีดยาฉีดยาฉีดยาฉีดยา
บ่อยมากๆ
อืโอ้โหต้องฉีดยาฉีดยาฉีดยาบ่อยๆเลยหรอ
ใช่แล้วิมก็รู้สึกเหนื่อยมากเอออืเหนื่อย
เหนื่อยแล้วเรียมก็แบบเ้อเจอหมออีกแล้ว
ฉีดยาอีกแล้วเรียมแบบไม่ชอบ
อืแม่เด็กๆจะไม่ชอบหมอนะคะใชอืมนั่นใช่
แต่ก็แบบแต่ก็ผ่านมาได้เรียมก็ดีขึ้นฉีดย
ครูเรียมนอนโรงพยาบาล
มั้ยจำได้แอดมิือ
เปล่าตอนนั้นแบบไม่ไม่อืไม่ได้นอนแต่กลับ
มาที่บ้านมานอนที่บ้านแล้วก็แม่ก็พาไปโรง
พยาบาลอีกแล้วก็กลับมาที่บ้านมานอนที่
บ้านอือือแต่ว่าจำได้แค่ว่าฉีดยาฉีดยา
บ่อยๆอืๆๆนี่ไงเห็นมยปอดบวมเนี่ยก็ต้อง
ฉีดยาบ่อยๆใช่มั้ยคะฟ้าไม่เคยปอดบวมก็เลย
ไม่รู้ว่าเป็นยังไงป่วยหนักมยอะไรอย่าง
งี้อือันนี้ก็หมายถึงป่วยนะอืๆๆๆไม่สบาย
อืแต่ว่าแบบบางคนน่ะถ้าเกิดแบบปอดปอดไม่
ดีก็อาจจะเป็นเพราะสูบ
บุหรี่ใช่ค่ะอืก็จะแบบคนสูบุหรี่ปอดไม่ดี
หรือโควิดไม่แข็งแรงโควิดโควิดก็ปอดใช่มย
อ่าโควิดก็เกี่ยวกับปอดนะคะนักเรียนเป็น
โควิดปอดก็จะไม่ดีอืนั่นแหละแต่ตอนนี้ยัง
ไม่ได้เป็นนะคุณเรียมยังไม่เป็นใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่เรียมแค่รู้สึกว่าเวลาที่อากาศ
หนาวเรียมจะรู้สึกหนาวมากกว่าคนอื่น
อืใช่โองั้นตอนนี้ครูเลียมก็น่าจะหนาวมย
เพราะว่าประเทศไทยหนาวนะคะตอนนี้ออใช่
หนาวเวลานอนก็เลยต้องเอาผ้าห่มมาห่มตรง
นี้ไว้อืมปอดใช่ปอดใช่ปอดของเรานะคะอใช่
ตอนนี้ก็ยังต้องทำแบบนั้นอยู่อืเพราะว่า
ครูเรียมหนาวใช่มากกว่าคนอื่นอืใช่แล้ว
ครูฟ้าล่ะคะครูฟ้าเคยแบบป่วยหนักหนักมากๆ
มป่วยหนักมากๆเหรอคะเอ่อครูฟ้าเคยป่วย
หนักมากๆตอนอายุ
ประมาณ 7 ขวบมั้งวะยังเป็นจุจูเนียร์ไฮ
School แบบจูเนียร์อยู่เลยอ่ะเออป 4 ป 5
หรือเปล่าอืมคิดว่าจะประมาณ 6 ขวบ 7 ขวบ
นะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยป่วยเพราะว่ามียุงนัก
เรียนกัดเราเนี่ยเนี่ยแหละค่ะยุงนะคะ
เรียนยุงูฟ้าโดนยุงกัดแล้วเป็นเด็งกี่
อืเป็นเดงอไเลือดออกใช่ค่ะหว่าใคร่เลือด
ออกนั่นแหละค่ะยังไม่ถึงกับมาลาเลียนะคะ
เป็นแค่เด็งกี่นะคะแล้วก็พอยุงกัดครูฟ้า
เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็เริ่มตัวร้อนใช่มะ 39 องศ
เซซไม่รู้นะคะจำไม่ได้แต่ว่าตัวร้อนนะคะ
แล้วก็ตาใช่มยตาเนี่ยแสบตาแสบตามากเลยแสบ
ตาลืมตาไม่โอเคเท่าไหร่อือออืแล้วก็ตัวภู
ฟ้าเนี่ยก็จะมีสีแดงๆสีแดงสีแดงสีแดงสี
แดงสแดงจุดใชเป็นจุดค่ะนักเรียนจุดจุดๆจุ
ๆๆๆสีแดงๆอืที่ขากับที่แขนใช่คุณแม่ครู
ฟ้าก็เลยพาครูฟ้าไปโรงพยาบาลนะคะไป
แอดมิแล้วคุณหมอก็บอกว่าอ้าเป็นเดงกิใคร
เล่น
ออกใช่วก็เลยต้องนอนโรงพยาบาลค่ะครูเรียม
อืนอนโรงพยาบาลครูฟ้านอนที่โรงพยาบาลกี่
วันประมาณ 7 วันมั้งจำไม่ผิดออน่าจะ 7
วันนะคะ 7 หรือ 14  7 วันต้องฉีดยา
มั้ยฉีดยามีฉีดยาด้วยนะคะแต่ว่าครูฟ้า
ต้องเจาะเลือดเราบอกว่าเจาะเลือดนะคะนัก
เรียนก็คือมันจะมีเหมือนแบบเป็นเข็มใช่มย
แล้วก็เจาะเจาะเจาะเจาะเจาะเจาเจจเจาะ
หน่อยมากใช่มยใช่ะเจาะ 10 นิ้วเลยนะคะ
เจาะเลือดเจาะเลือดเจาะเลือดเจาะๆเจทุก
วันอ๋อเอาไปเช็คใช่มยว่าแบบดีขึ้นมั้ยใช่
ใช่ค่ะต้องเจาะทุกวันเลยนะคะเห็นมอเภูพะ
ก็เจ็บนะคะเพราะว่ายังเป็นเด็กอยู่แล้วก็
โดนเจาะเลือดโดนเจาะเลือดทุกวันแบบนี้มัน
ก็ไม่โอเคใช่มยอืมอืนั่นแหละก็เลยอันนั้น
คือป่วยหนักที่สุดแล้วใช่มั้ยคะูฟ้าใช่
ค่ะป่วยหนักที่สุดก็คือเป็นเด็งกี่นั่น
แหละอืก็ไปนอนโรงพยาบาลนะคะแล้วครูพ้านอน
โรงพยาบาลแค่ตอนเป็นเด็งกี่ 1 ครั้งหลัง
จากนั้นครูฟ้าก็ไม่ได้นอนโรงพยาบาลอีกเลย
อืออืใช่เมก็จำไม่ได้นะแต่เท่าที่จำได้ก็
ไม่ไม่ได้นอนโรงพยาบาลแต่ว่ากลับมานอนที่
บ้านแล้วก็ไปโรงพยาบาลแล้วก็กลับมาที่
บ้านหือดีแล้วครูเรียมนอนโรงพยาบาลเนี่ย
ครูฟ้ากลัวนะ
คะไม่ชอบนอนโรงพยาบาล
อืน่ากลัวนิดหน่อยแต่ก็นั่นแหละครูฟ้า
เนี่ยก็ป่วยบ่อยๆแต่เคยนอนโรงพยาบาลแค่ 1
ครั้งนะคะพอหายจากเด็งกี่แล้วพก็อาจจะมี
ไม่สบายไม่สบายแต่ไม่ต้องแอดมิไม่ต้องนอน
โรงพยาบาลแล้วอื
อืครูเรียมก็เคยนอนโรงพยาบาลมั้ยป่วยหนัก
เคยไม่ใช่ตัวเองป่วยแต่ว่าแบบคนอื่นป่วย
แล้วเราก็เลยแบบต้องไปนอนนอนเพราะว่าแบบ
นอนเฝ้าคนป่วยอืๆๆๆๆเออนั่นแหละมีคนป่วย
แล้วเราก็เลยแบบไปนอนไปนอนแล้วก็มีคนป่วย
นอนอยู่บนเตียงอือแต่ว่าถ้าเกิดให้เรียม
ป่วยหนักแล้วตัวเองไปนอนโรงพยาบาลไม่
เคยแต่ป่วยหนักนะแต่นอนอยู่บ้านไม่รู้
เหมือน
กันคือบางทีเนี่ยก็ต้องถ้าป่วยหนักๆแล้ว
ต้องนอนโรงพยาบาลก็คือคุณหมอต้องเช็คใช่
มยแต่ถ้าคุณหมอไม่ต้องเช็คเราก็อาจจะกลับ
ไปนอนที่บ้านได้อืมจะเป็นไปได้เนาะแล้วก็
มีอีกนะที่เรียมเคยเคยป่วยคิดว่าป่วยหนัก
นะเป็นไข้หวัดใหญ่อืไข้หวัดใหญ่หรอใช่ไข้
หวัดใหญ่ก็จะตัว
ร้อนไข้วัดใหญ่จะมีตัวร้อนมากๆนะคะแล้วก็
ปวดตัวร้อนมากนะปวดตัวอืปวดปวดปวดๆปปวด
ตัวนะคะปดใช่เรี่มก็จะนอนนอนนอนทั้งวัน
นอนทั้งคืนนอนทั้งวันนอนทั้งคืนใช่แล้ว
กินกินอาหารกินข้าวไม่อร่อย
อืทำไมยมกินแบไม่อร่อยไม่กินไม่อยากกิน
ข้าว
อื
นอนอืคือการเป็นครูฟ้าไม่เคยเป็นไข้หวัด
ใหญ่นะคะก็เลยไม่รู้แต่เป็นไข้หวัดใหญ่
เนี่ยก็อาจจะปวดตัวงมากแล้วก็ต้องนอนเยอะ
ๆถูกมั้ยใช่กินข้าวไม่อร่อยใช่อืแบบน้ำ
หนักลดอ่ะ
อืสมมุติสมมุติว่าหนักหนัก 25 ตอนเด็กนะ
ไม่ใช่ตอนนี้หนัก 25 กก็จะน้ำหนักลดเหลือ
23 ตอนที่เป็นไข้หวัดใหญ่ออเพราะว่าไม่
กินข้าวอืเห็นมั้ยแต่ครูเรียไม่นอนโรง
พยาบาลใช่มั้ยคะไม่ค่ะอืไม่นอนโรงพยาบาล
นอนอยู่ที่บ้านคิดว่าโอเคอือๆแค่นอนตอน
นั้นเรียมเข้าโรงเรียนแล้วอืเรียมก็เลย
ต้องเขียนเอาปากกาเขียนจดหมายอืจดหมาย
ลาให้ครูเขียนจดหมายแล้วเอาจดหมายไปให้
ครู
อืใช่แล้วทีนี้แบบแล้วก็นอนป่วยอยู่หลาย
วันมากค่ะนอนๆๆนอนไม่ทำอะไรเลยอืแล้วเร็ม
ก็กินนมอ่ะดื่มนมนิดนึงก็นอนกินยานอนอื
ประมาณประมาณ 4-5 วันได้นะ
อ๋อนานมากออ 4 วันถึง 5 วันนะคะใช่อก็แบบ
รู้สึกดีขึ้น
อืก็แบบมา
เดินใช่เดินเล่นแล้วก็กลับไปโรงเรียนได้
อือืเวลาประมาณ 4 วัน 5 วันใช่ที่จำได้นะ
ประมาณ 4 วัน 5 วันค่ะก็นั่นแหละคือไข้
หวัดใหญ่มัน
จะนักเรียนอาจจะเป็นใช่มยแบบต่างประเทศ
ที่ยุโรปต่างประเทศเวลาหนาวๆก็จะมีไข้
หวัดใหญ่นักเรียนก็ต้องไปฉีดวัคซีนนะคะ
มันจะมีวัคซีนของไข้หวัดใหญ่เนาะอืมคนไทย
ไม่ค่อยฉีดูพักก็ไปฉีดวัคซีนไข้หวัดใหญ่
เหมือนกันน่าจะอืูพ้าได้ฉีดไงเไม่จำไม่
ได้อ่ะภูฟ้าจำไม่ได้นะคะว่าภูฟ้าฉีด
วัคซีนไข้หวัดใหญ่หรือเปล่าไม่ชัวร์แต่คน
ไทยจะไม่ค่อยกลัวเท่าไหร่ไม่กลัวไข้หวัด
ใหญ่เออแต่ไข้หวัดใหญ่เนี่ยเวลาไม่สบายก็
จะไม่สบายมากๆเลยนะนักเรียนหรือว่าป่วย
หนักเลยนะคะอใช่ก็ต้อง
นอนก็ต้องนอนถูกต้องค่ะใช่ค่ะก็อันนี้คือ
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าก็ไม่เคยเป็นเนาะใขวัดใหญ่
ไม่เคยคิดว่าครูฟ้า
ไม่ไม่
รู้เวลาครูฟ้าไม่สบายครูฟ้าก็ไม่สบายมากๆ
นะแต่ว่าไม่รู้ว่าเป็นไข้หวัดใหญ่มยน่าจะ
ไม่เคยเป็นไข้หวัดใหญ่นะคะคิดว่าไม่เคย
ไข้หวัดใหญ่ต้องปวดอ่ะปวดตัวอใช่ๆมันต้อง
ต้องปวดตัวก่อนหน้านี้ก็มีป่วยนะคะประมาณ
1 เดือน 2 เดือนที่แล้วมั้งไม่รู้ว่า
เป็นไข้หวัดใหญ่หรือเปล่ามันปวดตัวมากนะ
คะเพราะว่าคุณพ่อูฟ้าเป็นแล้วก็นั่นแหละ
อืครูฟ้าก็เป็นด้วยใช่แต่ครูฟ้าไม่รู้ครู
ฟ้าไม่ได้ไปโรงพยาบาลครูฟ้าไม่ได้เช็ค
เอ่าไม่ได้ฉีดยาครูฟ้านอนแล้วก็กินยาเอา
นะคะออแล้วก็โอเคขึ้นอืประมาณกี่วัน
คะ 1 อาทิตย์มั้งจำไม่ได้ 7 วันใช่น่าแต่
1 อาทิตย์นะคะอาจจะเป็นไข้หวัดใหญ่ก็ได้
นะแต่แค่ไม่ได้ไปหาหมอก็เลยไม่รู้ใช่ก็
เลยไม่รู้นะคะนั่นแหละคือการป่วยหนักใช่
มยครูเรียมก็มีป่วยหนักครูฟ้าก็มีป่วย
หนักนักเรียนก็น่าจะมีป่วยหนักนะคะอืใช่
แต่บางทีไม่ได้ไปหาหมอไม่ได้ตรวจก็ไม่รู้
ค่ะเหมือนที่บางคนบอกว่าไม่ได้ตรวจโควิด
ก็ไม่ได้เป็นโควิดอใช่ก็ไม่รู้ไม่เช็คอื
ไม่ได้ไปตรวจไม่ได้ไปเช็คก็ไม่รู้ใช่มใช่
อือนั่นแหละอันนี้ก็คือเรื่องแบบเกี่ยว
กับเป็นไข้หรือว่าป่วยแบบที่ป่วยหนักกัน
นะคะวันนี้ที่แบบคุยกันกับครูฝ่าได้เลย
ค่ะครูเรียมแต่ว่าหมดเวลาหรือยังน่าจะหมด
เวลาใช่เหลืออีก 1 นาทีแต่ก็เหมือนหมด
เวลาแล้วแหละเอออยฟังอยากฟังจากนักเรียน
ว่านักเรียนเคยป่วยหนักยอืแล้วต้องนอนที่
โรงพยาบาลหรือเปล่าใช่ค่ะนักเรียน
คอมเมนต์บอกได้นะคะเล่าให้ครูฟังก็ได้อื
แต่ว่าใช่แล้วค่ะตอนนี้ก็เวลาหมดแล้วแง
แล้วอืก็เจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะนัก
เรียนอืใช่แล้วค่ะวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้ว
ค่ะครูป๊าได้ค่ะครูครูเรียมก็สวัสดีค่ะ
ครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะหวังว่าจะไม่มีใครป่วย
หนักนะใช่
ค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ